hey guys Jay Cargill here The Undefeated
TBS champion at all eat wrestling and
you're gonna catch me on bootleg kev's
podcast let's go
bootleg Kev show special guest
one of my favorite new up-and-coming
wrestlers she's 48-0 48 no okay so Jade
break this down
the brace the 50. it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen hell we might as well brace
ourselves for a hundred at this point
and you're familiar with the run that
Goldberg was on like in like when I was
a kid I'm familiar I'm very familiar I I
feel like they're kind of setting you up
to have a similar path yeah I can see
that but like this is Jade cargo's show
so like I that sounds great and
everything phenomenal phenomenal uh
wrestler he was but he was okay let's be
well okay this is my legacy
he looked the part yeah he did hey I
looked apart but I'm only gonna get
better like in all the women that I'm
being compared to they've been doing
this for five six seven eight years with
the best trainers repetition House shows
and I'm just out there just winging it
and doing the best I can on live TV I
think everybody should be grateful that
they're seeing this product come to
light right so for people who don't know
uh you're fairly new to wrestling yes
how long before he like was it Mark
Henry that found you yes how long like
are we talking here from like the first
time you got into a a gym and started
trying to learn how to take bumps and
yeah and stuff like that to now
two years so it's not even now not even
that not even that not even that and
like most so other promotions right
there's well the big the big other big
promotion right there's House shows
throughout the week that aren't on TV so
people can kind of like learn without it
being like memed with the same partner
yes right yeah usually on the house
shows you always are wrestling with the
same person as you know that you're on
TV with so you're just kind of like
really out here obviously you're
training when you're not on TV but like
all your high pressure situations you're
we're kind of going through it with you
yeah I mean for example the first time I
used a chair I remember uh CM Punk was
like you have to choke it up like this
and like because they were like oh yeah
you're gonna use a chair I was I'm gonna
use a chair I've never used a chair in
my life how do I use a chair and no one
gave me instructions other than him to
show me how to use a chair and I had to
perform this on live TV and we'll soon
punks ago that's why yeah yeah
so you you use the chair for the first
time ever ever on TV on TV how'd that
goat is uh it was pretty interesting
that was a pretty uh that was uh last
year let's just move forth I've learned
my lesson and uh it's gonna get better
because how because for people because
there's a an art to everything yes and
I'm a huge wrestling fan and I always
tell people like
I feel like wrestling is one of the most
D like it it is Art it is truly I love
that you said that yes it is it is an
art form that is of the highest
difficulty physically uh mentally
mentally all of that stuff uh and there
is an art to everything you guys do
including how to hit somebody with a
[ __ ] chair so don't kill them yeah so
how do you do it I can't tell you that
what you're trying to get me like caught
up over here but I will say that is it
is an art you don't want to completely
destroy your opponent where they can't
come back next week and perform or
something like that but it's all in our
we're artists and we're trying to paint
a picture for a story of course that our
audience can follow and just respect and
of course like you have to you guys have
to trust each other in the ring because
yes everybody is trying to get home at
the end of the day yes yeah very much so
very much so what like because with
anybody who's new to wrestling I'm sure
you had moments where
moves get botched or things don't go how
you got to keep going you got to keep
going but like do you feel like there
was a certain time or are you still
getting to the point where you feel like
you're hitting your stride in terms of
pulling up because you pull off some
pretty crazy [ __ ] yeah I I have a long
way to go and I understand that I'm
getting more comfortable with the the
Reps I'm having I mean this year I think
I had under this year alone I think I
had under 20 matches this year and when
it comes to more than a five minute
match I think I had less than 10 and the
majority of your favorites when you say
this year you mean 2023 or 2022 2022.
okay I'll come back
but wait your favorites probably have 10
matches in like two months yeah not even
that I mean like for sure so for me not
to have these men this these winning
matches you know this can can do a lot
to you mentally and physically because
I'm not used to getting these reps in
and me practicing Jade cargo can only
get to her biggest form live yeah and
the more people the more I'm into my
character so if we have like a dark
taping with like 50 people I can't get
into my character the way I really want
to get into my character unless I see a
sea of people because I like that's why
I do all my heat outside because I like
interacting with the audience or I tell
the audience hey you idiots count to ten
or five or whatever I love interacting I
love them saying Oh you suck or this guy
was like you're 5'2 in person I was like
get the [ __ ] out of here and I like but
I had to stop because we're on TV and I
gave her um a choke slam and I literally
was like get the
can't say it and I went over to him and
I said something but um
I have a long way to go I'm like I said
your favorites have been in this game
for like five seven Brian told me he
didn't get comfortable until like seven
years wow so the fact that I'm on
national TV I'm pulling off moves and
like I'm doing all the transitions [ __ ]
for sure thank you and like to and the
funny thing is like I can do the big
moves they're easy like it's more so
like can my partner take the move or
like take this big bump but I can do all
these moves I was a power lifter for a
long time yeah well you were saying
earlier before we were on camera that
you've lived through like five lives I
did so what were you doing prior to
being a superstar wrestler on aew
um so I was a Collegiate basketball
player D1 Collegiate basketball player
went overseas for two years played
basketball over there right
um Jacksonville University it's a D1
University we're uh we're overseas
um lahaf in uh Normandy you know where
that France France okay it's yeah yeah
it's Pro uh Pro a so then I'm a child
psychologist I was a stay-at-home mom
and then I supported my spouse who
played baseball so I I did a couple
things probably this but also it made me
when I got back into well when I got the
opportunity to get into sports I didn't
want to let it go so does your spouse I
want a trainer sorry you're still with
your spouse I am I when you were with
him he was in the league yes so now does
he get to kind of relax yeah guys kind
of switch positions yes while you're
running around and traveling and
Performing and yeah when he's a
stay-at-home dad but also we just um
brought into a softball team so we own
we're the fourth owners of a softball
team wow so there's only four uh teams
out in the league right now and it's
going to be in Dallas so that and then
he's the co-owner for the Lexington
Legends so right now who's your spouse
Brandon Phillips okay so he yeah he
played for the Reds the Braves and won a
ring with the Boston Red Sox he's Rick
yeah he's just relaxing right now 17 you
know a bit but
he's at home taking care of our daughter
and I'm on the road right now and I
couldn't be more ecstatic because I love
it it's like fun and I don't need to do
it like I can go home sit on my ass and
make more money like pleasing my spouse
than like doing all this but I do it
because I love it yeah I love it now we
always hear that like when like just the
wrestlers grind it's very uh taxing very
and right now you guys aren't doing
House shows like uh other other
companies right right but you guys are
still traveling
um how hard is it to juggle being a mom
being a wife having all this other stuff
going on while also being on the road
while also you know you're the premier
Talent on the female it's a lot it's a
lot you know we get home on Thursdays
majority of the time and my daughter
who's five the first thing she does is
want to play with me and I'm like baby
girl please like let me just take a nap
I've been up since four and I had to get
on this flight right after I probably
got maybe 30 minutes of sleep if
anything and thankfully I have a sport I
mean a sport a husband who played in
sports who understands like the grind
and the fact that I need a break and I
need to relax like I got home this week
he sent me out with a massage and
everything like that like he does stuff
like that because he understands how
much it is as far as taxing on your body
and on your mental and just a fan base
and if they don't like you or whatever
so
and the fact that I have a spouse who's
not in wrestling helps a lot because
only if I want to get away from the fan
base or anything like the negative
attention I could just put my phone down
that's all I have to do and he can care
less he's like you want to talk about
wrestling nope okay let's talk about
what do you want to talk about and I
appreciate that so it's a lot
um I couldn't imagine having more than
one child right now I want more children
but right now it's like uh hell no it's
no way I could do it but uh it's a lot
it's a lot you uh you said that you were
hanging out with CM Punk quite a bit yes
at Comic-Con uh what was something that
you learned from Punk because he's my
all-time favorite I love Punk just stand
on what you believe and and don't be a
pushover and I admired that because
coming into the business and being new
you know a lot of people it's like you
have to almost shrink yourself a little
bit yeah and I know who I am again I
live several lives I've lived real life
and just because I didn't want to do
this all my life or because I didn't put
in the time
I I refuse to let anybody look at me
less than and I refuse for anybody to
treat me anything different because
outside of these lines I'm a human
freaking being and you're not going to
treat me like anything else so
um I'm not saying that anyone treated me
any type of way I'm just saying in
Russian you hear about that yeah of
course of course especially on the
Indies and I I'm not familiar with the
Indies at all but I'm not going to be
walked over and I refuse for you to to
because I'm Jay Cargill and outside of
these lines I'm Jay Cargill so I'm not
going to let you address me anything
less so the fact that he told me to
stand on what I believe and don't be a
pushover that stuck with me he's a great
guy how crazy was backstage the night
that punk did that press conference with
Tony Khan sitting next to him and [ __ ]
hit the fan and it was like I was like
oh my God this is amazing I have no idea
so I wasn't there I had already left the
stadium I had already left um right
after my match I left I was like all
right like I'm out guys and so I heard
about it just like the rest of the world
at the same time yeah it was pretty
shocking um and I saw that look that
Tony Khan gave him like
yeah yeah but I mean I don't know for my
opinion Punk's a great guy he's been
nothing but nice to the women's locker
room he talks to me um tells me his
experience again at Comic-Con you know
we got really close because he was my my
tagged me in the interviews and I
learned so much from him and so much
knowledge in the industry and again he's
you know been in two different companies
and of course he's he can do whatever
the hell he wants to do so um he doesn't
need it right he does it because he
loves it and that to me speaks speaks to
me because I don't need it I do it
because I love it and I appreciate
people like that how did Mark Henry
discover you we had a mutual friend
named Kelsey and
um she asked me jokingly well she was
serious he's obviously a legendary
bodybuilder he was the World's Strongest
Man and his friend Kelsey our mutual
friend is a bodybuilder and uh she
jokingly asked me about it but she was
serious I was joking about it and I was
like wrestling I haven't watched
wrestling since like I was like 14 years
old talking about wrestling and she was
like yeah so she had a series face
series tone right and I said okay well
let me try this out all right I'll do it
and she was like okay well I really know
a Hall of Famer named Mark Henry and he
can get you into a tryout and I want to
try out and it lit a fire under my butt
and I never wanted to let it go since
then wow yeah yeah what up we gotta stop
the interview real quick to tell you
about our family over at my bookie
that's right Lots going on in basketball
right now Lots going on in the NFL
playoffs are about to start Super Bowls
coming up so much to gamble on let's win
some money go to my bookie right now if
you sign up for a new account
mybookie.ag
you can gamble from wherever you're at
yes go to my bookie and use the promo
code bootleg when you sign up for that
new account and they will match your
first deposit up to one thousand dollars
that's free money in your pocket uh that
you can gamble with so if you put a
thousand bucks in your account they're
gonna give you another thousand dollars
to gamble with so go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up with that
new account one more time they will
match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars all right so like maybe
you want to put 200 bucks on the Cowboys
or some [ __ ] to win the Super Bowl
you're gonna lose that money because
[ __ ] the Cowboys but let's say you do
want to put some money on the Cowboys
you sign up you put 200 they give you
another 200. on top of that free money
to gamble with is called the double
deposit bonus and you can only get it by
using the promo code bootleg so go to my
bookie right now sign up for an account
let's get back to the interview it's fun
I enjoy I enjoy talking [ __ ] to the
audience I love people telling me what I
cannot do because I'm gonna do it 10
times over it's like my dream to be like
somehow in a ring at a pay-per-view yeah
in some way in my life I'll get [ __ ]
if I get famous enough where I could
just go out there and get [ __ ] up like
they pull really you want to do that
I'll be like front row and I get pulled
over and I gotta take a bump or get
thrown I'm gonna take a table really
please oh my gosh you sound like me I
can't wait to bleed for the first time
to have like a street fight and like the
shot of the blood just go oozing through
my face and my hair and like I don't
know what I'm doing I have to get a new
wig when I go to the airport but yeah I
know I can't wait I'm yeah and AWS
they've had some bloody moments so far
plenty yeah plenty so whenever I have my
first street fight I mean if I allow
them to even touch me then I can't wait
because I'm gonna like just
I'm excited that sounds wild though but
that sounds just as wild as you saying
you want to go through a table yeah put
me I would love to get put through a
table but even if it's by like uh you
know like a master job or like Dolph
Ziggler or somebody you know
you want to go through a table
regardless yeah all right yeah all right
let's maybe let's go through the table
one day yeah maybe if I can't touch them
oh my gosh
greatest rapper of all who who what's
his real name I don't know Shad Moss
team Moss bruh I don't even know what
happened okay okay so help me yeah so
this Bow Wow thing right yeah how much
of the Bow Wow thing was like storyline
like uh he's obviously a very small guy
very he's kind of small and round now
the 30s have hit it just like they hit
me he didn't look that I mean he he
doesn't look ground at all I think he
just you know feels out in the face a
little but other than anything
yeah it's a trick but yeah so so
obviously the the bow I think was
overshade it was like everywhere yeah
like how much of that was like uh
because break down the Bow Wow storyline
and and was it like mostly some
storyline [ __ ] on TV or you know like
like what happened
I don't know what happened with it yeah
um something was supposed to happen it
didn't happen and we moved on from the
situation did you ever listen to him
growing up I did I think everybody did
but I was more of a Romeo fan really I
was more of a Romeo fan I like bow wow
they both kind of ran 106 in park
as a kid I watched kind of but I played
basketball so I was out like at practice
when that came on when did I come on
like seven some seven yeah yeah uh how
how do you compare like the basketball
grind to the wrestling grind which one's
harder because you played real I mean
you played division one and you played
overseas so yeah
um maybe and obviously that's why I was
done with it because women didn't make
that much money and so I quit because of
that and also it was just I felt like I
was missing out on all my friends and
them living life and like they couldn't
visit me all the time because they had
jobs so I was like this is great and all
like I'm experiencing life and like
traveling but I want to go back home and
be with my friends yeah and even if like
the peak of being a female basketball
players the WNBA like financially that's
not that [ __ ] great respect they made
as much as the men I would be out there
shooting even if they right now 20 of it
nothing one percent I think makes who
makes the most money I don't I don't
know I think that's right yeah I think
she does but she doesn't make more than
like I'm just gonna throw a crazy number
out there then 12 million dollars no she
don't I don't I don't so no I honestly
think she makes like 200 Grand a year
yeah I swear to God I don't think it's
that much you're lying see that's that's
so I don't understand
right and listen shout out to Brittany
granter glad she's home there's a reason
why she had to go to uh Russia yeah yeah
well a lot of these so overseas a lot of
these um these leagues they lock you in
to where they give you a contract that
says Hey I want you to stay here in like
Tel Aviv and not play in the WNBA
because of the season so they'll do that
but they'll pay you way more over there
and depending like if you're a Monaco is
tax-free yeah so I mean overseas is
where it's at when it comes to women
making money as far as basketball but
you're missing out on like home life
that's the only thing that sucks about
it and you have to have an insane level
of unhealthy fans in terms of like step
on me fans some of the weird [ __ ] they
say to you yeah I can only imagine your
DMs are okay they could probably be a
dark place every once in a while yeah
whoa I used to get those kind of
pictures all the time and I think
because now I post my family a little
more and my spouse they kind of like
back off more so but you know people
like that domination stuff so I just
feel like yeah I feel like uh I just I
just feel like men are very creepy they
can be oh wrestling come on wrestling
fans and and I was gonna say when you
throw into the mix okay there's a great
male wrestling fans yeah and there's a
whole [ __ ] just yeah God bless them
I'm a male wrestling fan I mean I'm
married and you know I get laid but like
a lot of them
so you're admitting that you're weird
you said earlier you are weird
no I'm a normal I'm like of the minority
of us okay people who watch wrestling
okay but you know there's a lot of those
guys yeah I oh yeah I get a lot but in
person they get afraid yeah they get
timid they get afraid they really don't
say much like they'll say oh can I get a
picture
have you had people send you unsolicited
nude photos of themselves yeah I have I
mean but everybody does I think I mean
no I mean okay all right well maybe
maybe my man used to go to different
cities and women would be in his DMS and
all kind of crazy stuff so you know yeah
he's a pro athlete I'm not see there's
there's a difference in our income
levels yeah yeah no I can only imagine
what that's like to like be like that's
I feel like that's like [ __ ] a form
of sexual assault like bro is it it
feels like it should be these people
have like cats as like their default
pictures so I wouldn't be able yeah
you're a dog person I'm a cap well I'm
about I'm both I have both yeah I have
both yeah but the cats are easy to deal
with in a dog but they're they're so
they you know the cats they handle them
but they're total [ __ ] like they just
and that's the reason my cat I love her
but like she just she don't want to be
touching when we touch your cat ever
beat up your dog yes yeah yeah that's
the only reason I want to get a cat I
tell my wife all the time because we
have a Frenchie and a Pomeranian yeah
I just want to get a cat so you can just
box the [ __ ] out of the French Bulldog
and we've gone Tick-Tock that's horrible
my cat doesn't like our dog but our dog
is like a miniature it was a miniature
King Charles so it's like it's just it's
yeah it is it's a small little dog but
he's like well she is so scary so like
she'll let the dog like the cat just
beat her up and I'm like come on man
you're a dog like come on those cats are
just they're serious look at their same
age yeah
um you're from Florida Rick Ross has
been a on AW a lot recently have you ran
into him backstage I have sweet guy nice
guy
um very professional guy and the what
you see from him that's like him they
don't rehearse they just go out there
and just spit but also he's an
Entertainer so that's what he does so
when it comes like to the Bow Wow
situation that was just an Entertainer
he'll just spit and that's what they do
as entertainers like Shaq when he came
and he performed with me before going
out he was like I said don't embarrass
me he's like don't you embarrass me and
he's an Entertainer he said he was your
taxi partner yeah so my first match with
Cody Rhodes and red velvet he looked at
me dead in my eyes and said they're
gonna eat and like anything I do out
there because I'm an Entertainer so yeah
and he was like so you don't embarrass
you yeah I was like what like but I
thought that was funny but that was your
first match ever ever that's why I'm
saying like people are watching that was
my prior to that I had an off-grid match
where I was a face
and it was like five minutes and that
was the only match I've ever had ever
prior to my debut and most people have
plenty of house shows and and so many
reps and like have perfected I didn't
know I was turning Hill until well I
thought it was gonna be a phase and the
first night I went out there to do my
promo they're like yeah you're going
through the Hilton huddle and I was like
wait so does that mean I'm a hill like
yeah you're a hill I'd love to be a heel
so it's fun it's [ __ ] yellow it's fun
I love it I would like I want to make a
child cry in the audience every night I
go out there that's what I would want to
do I flicked some kids off but I have a
kid right no no if somebody messes with
my kids I just want to do something to
their hero okay that makes them cry oh
well you gotta mess with them too yeah
you got to like yo that's why your mom's
cheating on your [ __ ] dad oh my gosh
well have you seen mjf well Max Max does
it yeah no yeah yeah so you you this
whole this whole time you've been a heel
for the most part right yes that's all
I've been is a hill but I get cheered
and I'm like what the [ __ ] can I say
that yeah yeah okay all right yeah yeah
well our company is not publicly traded
it'll be all right no it'll be all right
let's be all right oh my God he's gonna
get me in trouble so what was so talk
about Shaq because uh Shaquille O'Neal
obviously is uh you know the man but to
me that's kind of a
that's a pretty wild first match you're
tag teaming with somebody who's not a
wrestler no but he's been in that in
that stage before at WWE so you're going
against uh Cody who's like the face of
the company yep how nervous were you I
wasn't nervous wow at all I think
because again I played college sports
and I've performed in front of thousands
of people and I've done All-Star games
and things of that sort of just you're
gonna get what you get and even when
like I've been out there and uh the
cheer shots or anything of that sort and
it's something I've never done before I
just I don't know like I have this thing
where it's like fight or flight and I'm
like Jade you know our fan how are fan
base is so you just gotta go out here
and do the best you can and it is what
the [ __ ] it is
how hard is it to get the promo part
down because it says I think it's almost
there's people who their entire WWF
career is based on their ability to rock
a mic you know or uh wrestling career
sorry I know what you meant but you know
what I mean
um so for you like how much work do you
put into mastering that part of the game
because it's as important as the in-ring
stuff it's like they're kind of one hand
watches the other a lot and I take
acting classes so it helps I take improv
classes it helps tremendously but also
my character is nothing but an extension
of myself right so me saying like I got
this I got money all this kind of stuff
like I do and I'm just I'm speaking from
the heart I'm just not as [ __ ] with it
like I'm really a chill laid-back person
like I'll post like a little stuff here
and there but I'm not showing you like
everything and I live in Atlanta so you
don't want to get robbed but so I don't
post everything but I heard it like it's
just me it's really hot even like in
Buckhead where it's like nice that's
where I start you stay in Buckhead I had
to move out it's wild yeah do you hear
gunshots at like two o'clock in the
morning three o'clock and our neighbor
the neighbors talk through like apps or
like did you is that gunshots and
they're like yeah that's gunshot so all
my neighbors moved out as well
hey what UPS bootleg cab here to uh stop
the interview and tell you about
Bluetooth yes do you have a dick does
your husband have a dick
maybe does your boyfriend got a dick
does your wife have a dick who knows
um it could be harder I'll tell you that
yeah blue chill gets your dick real hard
to kick off that new year you know what
I'm saying if you want your dick harder
than
Advanced trigonometry senior year high
school then go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg and get
one month supply for free that's right
free all you got to do is pay five
dollars in shipping
they're going to deliver the blue shoe
right to your [ __ ] door and discreet
packaging all right same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form
very discreet packaging mailed to your
house you don't have to go to a doctor's
appointment in person with anybody you
don't have to worry about embarrassing
conversations with strangers about your
[ __ ] dick bro nobody wants to talk
about their dick with a stranger I take
that back I take that back
lots of people like to talk about their
dicks with strangers
if you're not that kind of guy or girl
or them all you gotta do is go to
Bluetooth right now and use the promo
code
bootleg and you're gonna get it sent
straight to your door that's right they
also got the new mint chewable that's
the same active ingredients as Levitra
so there's a lot of options to get your
dick right in the New Year it's 2023.
yeah your dick shouldn't be flaccid
after a like nice long stressful night
no your dick should be ready you don't
want to be a you know a victim of too
much stress too much anxiety and then
you look down and you can't stay hard
you imagine how [ __ ] embarrassing
that is you get yourself a nice lovely
[ __ ] young lady you bring her to the
place you're nervous she's a little
maybe she's a little out of your [ __ ]
league and you start thinking too much
and that dick's not gonna perform it's
not it's not going to perform how you'd
like it to but you know how it will
perform if you're on that [ __ ]
Bluetooth
you're gonna put in a [ __ ] Luka
donkic 61 Point [ __ ] performance on
that [ __ ] all right so go to
bluetooth.com right now use that promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview
um do you ever go back and like uh watch
I just me and my boy uh we're just
talking who we thought me and my co-host
James we were just talking uh about uh
who we thought were the best uh
guys on the mic in wrestling history and
because I always dive into these like
YouTube rabbit holes of like promos and
like the rock or Paul Heyman or guys
like that or yeah Jericho was [ __ ]
amazing I mean CM Punk is like well
you're a CM Punk fan too he is the man
he is the man but do you ever go back
and like watch some of the uh the greats
and like some of the like some of the
methods that they use like a guy like
Jake The Snake was like one of the best
and he spoke with like he was calm with
it so I don't my thing is where I'm
trying to master is being able to talk
like this right but I'm supposed to come
off like a total like raging like Angry
woman and so I'm trying to master being
calm and collected and being able to
deliver exactly what the hell I want to
deliver in a raging way with a calm
voice which is Jake that's what Jake the
snake was in here so I'm trying to to
find that tone right now rather than
being like I'm that [ __ ] and like
yelling all the time so but when I'm in
the ring and I'm doing these promos like
my blood just starts pump jumping and
like I just get this energy and you hear
the crowd yelling and then that's when
the rage comes out and you start
screaming because you're starting to
feel it and I'm trying to just set back
the tone a little bit and like okay
y'all feel this but like I'll get to
where I need to go with the yelling
right now I need to keep it mellow so I
do check out all the Grays that's dope I
saw you uh hang out with Naomi who's
obviously sweet woman super cool chick
uh have any of the like veterans whether
they're with aw or not like reached out
to you to give you any pointers or
they're like maybe trying to be your big
homie yeah plenty plenty plenty a lot of
people in this business want me to
succeed when I say a lot of people a lot
of the veterans like all the old school
people that you see they want me to
succeed and they understand they see
money so they're like hey like one thing
they appreciate especially at all the
the old school guys at aw they're like
you know you look good like that that's
great like Sting he's like
a lot of people want this like you don't
have to do much like you don't have to
go out there and do all this flippy
stuff like you don't have to do all that
people want this like you don't have to
do a lot but let me help you fine-tune
these other things that you can do
because sting was a great looking
wrestler for sure and he came in and
just excelled but he understood like you
don't have to do a lot to get over and
do all these things so
the old school people they love the fact
when I say old school they're gonna kill
me when I say that I mean yeah like yeah
it was wrestling before I was alive well
the older our coaches and our agents
they appreciate the fact that one I come
in and daily and grind like I hit up
Brian every week like hey can we train
on Wednesday can we train on Wednesday
because I want to get better like I
didn't enter this sport to be good like
I don't want to transition into the next
thing until I'm great at this right and
people can talk like all the crap they
want everybody knows I'm gonna be great
at this and I say that with so much
confidence because I am and I put in the
work to say that and I've just started
and I'm getting compared to so many
amazing women that have been doing this
for so long and have the best of
everything and the fact that I've came
from nothing I didn't watch wrestling I
watch it and I study it now and I
respect it you can't beat that right so
I'm only going to get better and that's
undeniable so the veterans look at me
and they give me so much respect and
they give me so such great advice about
keeping my head clear and just focusing
and knowing that you're gonna be good
just don't you know don't be too cocky
don't get be so full of yourself where
it blinds you and it gets in the way of
your success how hard was it because
like you really didn't you say you you
really didn't watch wrestling right I
watched it until I was 14 but know like
obviously yeah I mean that was a long
time ago um but like is it like because
we always I at least perceive wrestling
to kind of be like it's like a
fraternity there's a lot of Unwritten
rules there's a lot of they they want to
they want to keep Outsiders out as much
as possible yeah
um it's like any industry right but it's
it's wrestling is like very much the
good old boys club it feels like so like
as an outsider coming in
um was there like a learning curve or
like a curve of dealing with maybe hate
or just trying to figure out the
politics of Backstage hate politics
um I think the experience I got at the
tryout gave me a lot of insights and um
Mark Henry again gave me a lot of advice
I go up to people ask for advice be kind
ask what can you do can you clean up
after Shake everybody's hand when they
talk you shut up like and I understood
that from playing basketball and having
someone take leak and that lead and I
think that me being an athlete prior
helped me in so many different ways and
directions with respect and just being
able to go out there and and dominate in
the ways that I have
um
also when I came into aw and when I won
the belt I mean I don't think anybody
would like that I just came in out of
nowhere these other girls have been
grinding on the Indies for years they
have a fan base like they've they've uh
they've given a lot of their time and
and work and all this kind of body to
the sport and here I am coming in and I
look good and it's like all right you're
kind of being shot to the top right now
but at the end of the day yeah they can
people can say it and feel the way they
feel but that's a lot on my shoulder now
because I've been giving a belt and I've
been put in a position that let's be
real I wasn't ready for but I know that
I have to step in these shoes and I have
to go out there and act like
everything's okay and mentally clear my
head and and focus and try to do the
best I can do
I think I'm doing perfectly fine in
regardless of how anybody felt in the
locker room I still only person that I
care about pleasing is Tony Khan that's
it hey boss you like what you've seen
great hey boss what you want that's all
that matters nice guy great guy she's a
great guy and he's like a fan first
right yeah he is right there like he's
so rich I'm like you want to get in the
wrestling business yeah well if you sit
down here and talk about old school
wrestling or any type of wrestling he
can tell you anything that you want to
know he's so in tune you want to talk
about boys club he's a part of that like
he loves wrestling so is Billy Gunn one
of your trainers he is right now he's my
agent so all my matches that you've seen
foreign
probably my last 10 matches he's done
he's been my agent for a great guy like
understands what I need and understands
the the that I don't need to do much and
that's what I appreciate from him
because he's a big guy and prior to that
I was working with great coaches but he
understood like hey he won he sold
tickets he puts asses in oh yeah one of
the greatest tag teams of all time of
course so and he has the body of I mean
you see his body at his age is freaking
wild and God bless him I know it's wild
so it is wild he understands yeah that
liver King diet he's good oh my gosh but
um he understands what it is to put
asses in seats for sure and he
understands what you need to do to get
over and not doing too much he's a very
much a minimum like minimalistic guy
when you see him out there does he put
you on like FaceTime with the road dog
Jesse James no he wants some like crowd
[ __ ] no no no no no he just talks from
his heart like he's he's great he talks
like one of my coaches and he plays
Sports prior so we just have that Sports
Connection where you can sit there and
he talks to me like a coach has the rock
tapped in yet no no you guys know from
Florida yeah listen I'm with I one thing
I want to be is the female rock that
might sound wild but I want to do that
no because when I say that people act
like it's like the end of the world and
it's like I don't understand why would
you shoot somebody's dreams if that's
what they want to be if they think they
can do that then hell somebody tomorrow
feel like they can I don't know hit rock
bottom on them if you can see go do it
you can do it oh yeah I could do movies
yeah I'm not worried about any of that I
know it's coming regardless of what
anybody says but I mean I have total
respect for this man and I Let's cross
our fingers
um I we just saw someone like uh Sasha
Banks uh leave one of the bigger U.S
promotions go go over to New Japan
wrestling
um the last 10 years has been like
insane in terms of just the female
wrestling world is like
you know when I was growing up it was
hard to get a female to a headline a
pay-per-view happens all the time now
yeah um the revolution is here and it's
been great like um when you think of
like
and and not obviously coming from you
who's who's not maybe as hardcore of a
wrestling fan but you've been in the
business a while now who who do you kind
of look up to in terms of other female
wrestlers that you might not necessarily
have a relationship with but you just
kind of you know um admire them for for
what they've done and what they're doing
I think Charlotte Fair is great I think
she's a very sound wrestler she can do
all the flippy [ __ ] that you wanted to
do she can go out there I have a
hardcore match I think she's a total
package that we have as far as an
example for a woman and she's like
[ __ ] she's a a lady yeah she she
leaves and comes back and then she like
it's like she never left yeah so I mean
I think she's phenomenal at what she
does people can talk what say whatever
they want I think she's a great wrestler
okay and you're a bodybuilder you're in
amazing shape thank you for somebody who
is uh like me or Bow Wow and probably on
the better side of our uh he keeps
bringing this guy up I don't know why
let's say we're in our 30s we're on the
you know the the our better days are
behind us
what diet should we go with should we go
with keto should we go with uh pot like
what are we doing it's not that easy I
would have to know like your percentage
I wouldn't have to know like so much
about you so when people
so when people ask me like hey what
should I eat I'm like I don't know
because I need to know your genetic
makeup what do you eat
um I eat whatever I want to eat I'm at a
point yes so what are you doing outside
explain that let me explain that because
you're explaining you're like you're in
a pristine condition yeah well let me
explain that so I eat whatever I want to
eat but it's relatively healthy food I
found what I like to eat so you like
healthy food you just don't know what
and it took me three years to figure it
out in a lot of money and like going
down the island picking stuff out and
looking out at all these healthy pages
and stuff so what do you stay away from
Pizza I'm not a big hamburger fan and
but I've like my palette has changed
like I don't because I don't eat that
stuff as much like
I don't really crave it as much only
thing I I do that's really bad is soda
that's it I love soda I know I know and
I'm my favorite I'm a country girl I
love me some Mountain Dew and that's the
worst that's the worst soda ever and
it's what it's so good I like Coke I
like Coke too but it like hits you it
depends you like the fountain drink or
like because the phone drink hits you
differently yeah it does hit you
different the thing about Mountain Dew
as a white guy I can't be white and
drink mountains why and be a wrestling
fan why not and be a wrestling fan I
can't do all three of those why what do
you mean why don't think I'm a [ __ ]
Juggalo that's not the shoot up a school
or something no Mountain Dew is good
it's not bad but I just I just can't be
the white dude who watches wrestling and
drinks Mountain Dew I I get it yeah I
get it I love Mountain Dew it's just so
bad it's so bad for you I know I know
it's so bad it's good do you just like
the normal Mountain Dew or the code red
or the Baja Blast I love the cold red
that's the best one but I can get enough
of it my son is obsessed with code red
it's the best well we get him like
bottles over for Christmas it's so good
but it has to be cold like it has to be
cold it needs to be cold but since you
like Coke put it in the freezer prior to
you drinking it and it's like the best
tasting Coke that you'll have I love
cold Coke but that's all they had
overseas that was like the same icy Coke
or there's something about McDonald's
Coke that hits different yeah like your
whole chest is on fire they got that
special concoction of syrup that goes
and then they got that and then they got
that orange High sea [ __ ] at McDonald's
you can't get nowhere else no oh my gosh
yeah you say you like soda when's the
last time you went to McDonald's and ate
food on the road probably like three
months ago I had some fries that's it
God bless you yeah I'm not big into like
fast food but I will eat it if it's a
cookie that I want to eat I'm gonna eat
that cookie or if I eat something bad
I'm just gonna get up in the morning and
work out how how are you working out
every day hey we got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at hardine that's right
Jardine Las Vegas the craziest
dispensary in the world the number one
dispensary in the United States let
alone in Las Vegas all right maybe
you're hitting Vegas with your friends
your girlfriends Whatever May it's a
bachelor party whatever's going on
you're going to go watch the Raiders
suck [ __ ] whatever it is make sure you
pull up to Hardy in Las Vegas tell them
I sent you they got the craziest
selection of Premium cannabis I've ever
seen in my [ __ ] life the pre-rolls
the cartridges the Edibles the flower
all top notch all the best the bud
tenders are so friendly it smells great
it smells so good inside a Jardine
that they have their own Harding
signature scent candle
ah see I sniff that and I just think of
Las Vegas and picking up some amazing
weed all right so go follow them right
now Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot
him a follow get all the details you
need you can get you some of this fly
ass Jardine merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview uh seven eight
well five days a week five days a week
Monday days like Monday through with our
schedule it's more so like uh Friday
through Tuesday are you doing two days
one a day what are we doing no two a
days no no well basically because I
train so I train like three calories
doing that anyway yeah so like two days
yeah like three four days a week wow
yeah it's a lot it is a lot yeah it's a
lot and then traveling and being on your
feet all the time being a mom yeah and
being on your feet yep it's a lot well
listen uh what's the next uh big
pay-per-view I heard Marcus had the
mattress life on Friday did I that's
what I just heard from Blake Blake was
telling me it was nice I had a great
time it was fun I'm starting so I'm
starting to just live in the moment and
that's something that Brian has always
been wait just somewhere clear who is
Brian Danielson oh
Daniel Bryan yeah that's your guy why is
that
does he still live in Phoenix with his
wife I'm not sure because I'm from
Phoenix and he was living there I think
he stays in like Washington or something
I love Daniel Bryan he's great he's such
a nice guy he's great too like but um I
[ __ ] love that guy oh my gosh she's
gonna say this over and over Brian he
loves you you don't understand I got all
the shirts
yes yes I got all that [ __ ] he's great
him and Kane is a tag team Team Hell No
oh my gosh so good then he finally won
the [ __ ] belt and he got injured it
broke my heart I almost cried honestly I
almost cried it made me sad SummerSlam
he's a nice what you see is what what he
like how he really is he's a really nice
guy he's not like he doesn't play off he
doesn't let people try him but like he's
a very sound guy so he's like training
you yeah wow he trains me on Wednesdays
yes like technically he's like one of
the greatest wrestlers ever I know and
Tony Khan is the one who set that up yep
he's great he's really really great but
um he told me he said the first thing he
always asked me when I come back is uh
like I'll say oh man I messed this up or
whatever I have to say he's like Jade
but did you enjoy yourself yeah and then
so now I'm living in the moment and like
before it's like four different layers
to like wrestling you have to listen to
this person this person but now I'm like
filling the crowd and I'm just listen to
her reaction yeah I know and he's just
like I don't know how you do it like
you're only two years here on national
TV and you're having to do this and that
and like that's astounding well he
grinded through Ring of Honor and
everything yeah he told me about all the
stuff like how he got comfortable uh
with promos was he would sing the
Star-Spangled uh Banner in UK like he
had to do that and he loves um karaoke
and so I was like oh he's like if you
want to get comfortable with doing
promos do karaoke like you should
definitely do karaoke and you'll be fine
wow so um but working with someone like
that I'm getting very comfortable in the
ring and uh like he's just like you need
to like just breathe in the audience
you'll have so much fun if you just like
live in the moment and like with the
hits and all this kind of stuff like
just breathe and like take it in and
listen like you're gonna be fine and now
I'm getting more comfortable and now I'm
getting more reps I just had three
matches like back to back with these
weeks like it's been helping
tremendously like that's all I need is
reps if we have House shows that's even
better for me but me having one match
and like once every two months it's
tough yeah yeah and then you're the
champ so they want you they don't want
you resting every week no no you know
I'm the prized possession yeah they got
to protect you you gotta get to you got
to get to 100 and no I am well let's
focus on 50 but we don't know what it's
100 yeah there's no way they're getting
you the 48 not getting you to 50.
there's just no way in hell that's gonna
happen I don't know let's see the
opponents I have lined up I don't know
enough wrestling over the years to know
you're getting to 50. I don't know
you're gonna get I don't know there's
they wouldn't drop the ball that's what
we like to call dropping they wouldn't
fumble the bag AAW is different I can't
fumble the back is there one storyline
that you've like predicted all the way
through
yeah I'm sure okay
what what which what was that I don't
know I just know that I've like uh
picked like full pay-per-views many
times okay me and my son will like put
our predictions together and uh usually
I do really well
okay well you know we never know we're
different we're totally different you'll
be 50 you know we'll see do you get free
Jacksonville Jaguars tickets if you want
to go watch Trevor Lawrence yes yes I
actually have a picture on and
everything super nice well I keep on
saying everybody's nice but they're nice
to me who's not nice
bread Baker's not nice you guys got some
little princess no I'm kidding she's
cool she's cool I'm cool with everybody
I don't think nobody's ever tried this
don't mention anybody okay but was there
anybody who was like
I can you had to have had some haters
being in a position where you are new to
the business and ascending as fast as
you have were there people who were
dicks yeah for sure yes of course but I
can say like one person that I did have
these talks with was Brit Baker because
she's in a tough position as well like
she's not even our champ right but she's
on TV she's right there with our champ
like she's on Flyers she's on this but
she puts asses and seats so that's one
woman I I had a heart to heart with and
we spoke about and like how do you deal
with it and she gave me some great
advice and now I could care and give a
[ __ ] less about any of that like I'm
placed in a position and I have to
understand I have to hold my head high
and keep it moving and I have to trust
in our owner that you know he put me in
this position for a reason hey shout out
to him smart guy hell yeah super people
can say what they want but he's
listening Hey listen smart calculated
man I swear I mean the stuff that AWS
pulled off in such a short amount of
time is like amazing and uh for you
um being
kind of the face of the female division
is that something that um do you feel
like do you've kind of carry that burden
with you like you know when you're
because you're kind of I mean you're the
biggest superstar in in the uh you're
the champ you're the hottest ship moving
right now right like do you feel that
[ __ ] like do you feel the pride of like
aew on your shoulders because there is a
big the biggest company that you guys go
against every week I do I do and I
respect it and that's why I put in the
work and I don't take this for granted
too because to even hold a belt it's a
privilege so I don't just go in there
and like lollygag and laugh about it
like I am representing my company every
time if I say when I'm carrying my bill
I always mention aw I always mention our
owner our owners are hard working lawyer
um owner he's just one of the South
division with the Jacksonville Jaguars
he is a soccer owner like I want money
huh I bet they make it they make a lot
of money
it's just wild he literally was just at
the show on Friday and then within 48
Hours was that the football game so I
mean like he's a hard-working man so I'm
not going to disappoint someone who's
literally in and out of air not even air
private airports every single day yeah
no he's not he's rich as hell he's a
billionaire why would he be oh I
wouldn't either get out of the PJ with
him no not yet it'll happen no not yet
but
um you know it's a burden but I wouldn't
even say it in a negative way like I'm
blessed and I'm gonna do nothing but get
better and he knows that and him working
with athletes he can tell and calculate
who's going to be good and who's not
like the man is a genius hey we got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
family at odd sucks that's right the
most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is a coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the beaves and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist and shout
out to all you rappers and people who be
pouring your lean into this [ __ ]
some Mountain Dew Baja Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview uh you said you want to
be the female rock yes the rock is a
very successful everything yes he's got
a very successful everything he's got
some energy drinks he's got a tequila a
tequila that only the Anejo is good the
Blanco's got awful
it's like it's like drinking fire water
oh my gosh with that being said
um what are do you have any business
ventures that you ASP I mean you already
obviously have some you have a softball
team uh but are there things you aspire
to get involved with as you as your
profile grows and movies but I think
that's something that all wrestlers want
to do is get involved in movies because
we're acting we're acting we're
improving like if something goes wrong
you just have to go with the flow like
we're doing so many different things
right now but comedy I want to get into
comedy more
um I'm a funny girl and uh I want to get
into acting I want to get into action
movies very much so
um I have the look I have to walk I want
to get into modeling I know I can do
that too and prior I was doing modeling
right so um I just want to focus on this
right now and then I can do I can juggle
all this at the same time I just want to
do it at the right time what's your
favorite comedy movies give me three
your top three uh Step Brothers is one I
think that's like my favorite one other
than that I mean everything else is kind
of separate is one of them ones though
that's number one that's the funniest I
got Friday and then okay well
technically would you say I mean Friday
is a comedy technically my favorite
movie ever is The Big Lebowski which is
behind you okay uh and that is a uh
that's a comedy okay well but I would
say Step Brothers is three three so
what's your second Big Lebowski Friday
and then Steph okay Friday's funny all
right I'll put up that I never thought
about my favorite
comedy movies I've thought more so about
my favorite movies like I love Titanic
Titanic don't judge me that's pretty
typical don't judge me don't it's not
typical that is not and I'm like okay
well my second one is New Jack City oh
great movie yes great I thought you were
gonna say The Notebook no and you were
gonna really just dig into the typical
[ __ ] oh no and I love the Titanic in the
notebook no I love it I love because
it's the only movie that has ever got me
to cry I don't know why every time The
Lion King didn't make you cry no it did
not oh I was [ __ ] crying no I was
crying on Titanic you know what movie
made me cry
that a lot of people because I when I
was a younger I watched the passions of
the Christ okay I haven't
to be honest with you though I'm a
I'm not very religious but for some
reason when I was like a kid I just felt
Jesus dying and I was like this is
[ __ ] I cried I can see okay I forgot
all about that movie well because an
anti-semite made it shout out to [ __ ]
Mel Gibson yeah dang I forgot all about
that movie okay all right well another
one is Hunger Games okay games made me
cry the first one yeah that made me cry
when Rue died made me cry okay but what
about your favorite TV shows what do you
watch on TV
um Family Guy I'm a big Family Guy
um I was watching it's a show on Netflix
um Alice in wonder was it Alice in
Borderland but I'm not I watched the
ending of it don't watch it watch the
first one don't watch the second one
um just Family Guy I don't really watch
TV like that watch wrestling I've been
watching wrestling did you watch the
competition I do just to get notes yeah
yeah I do why wouldn't you it'd be like
people who I got I have peacocks yeah if
you if you watch sports you're gonna
watch the other guys who do you know but
I have friends over there too so I watch
just to see like what's going on with
them and and you know like what they're
doing and we can have conversations you
should consume all things that will make
you better at your job yep for sure yeah
and I want to make sure we're not
stepping on each other's toes like I'm
not trying to say something that someone
else just said or I'm not trying to wear
something that they're wearing so I stay
on my toes and I try to make sure I'm
being respectful in the entire scheme of
things well I think you have to go watch
the shitty Clippers
um with that being said oh my God oh my
God I hope I hope you hear this Clippers
all right you're gonna lose all right so
why is Kawaii is injured
spoiler alert kawhi's not playing
tonight I don't even know if that's true
how's Paul George doing I don't know
he's a great player but he's always
injured too shout out to Palmdale uh
when's the next pay-per-view March I
can't remember but it's March okay
you'll be wrestling there uh yeah of
course I am when is the next time you're
wrestling for 49 enough I'm not sure I'm
not sure usually we get to work and if
it's not advertised it's like oh you
have a match and it's like okay one time
I had a match and literally had 30
minutes well 45 minutes to prepare for
it well you'll be 50-0 by March for sure
uh and I love them of course of course
of course of course and uh where do you
like last question before you go where's
the belt now like what do you do with
the belt you leave it in the hotel no I
actually I left it I left it in last
week because I didn't want to carry it
it's heavy it's heavy and then at that
like the real you have the real I have
two of the like 450 is is too much yeah
it's like every time I've missed three
flights because says they want to look
at it so they'll pull it out and like I
don't like the attention to everybody
like looking at it and then everybody's
like surrounding like oh what do you do
and and that starts until like a five
minute conversation I've missed three
flights because of it because they have
to screen it every freaking time and
pull it out and I'm just I'm like I'm
just gonna leave it so thanks for coming
no problem Jade appreciate you pulling
up uh go watch her on uh aw Wednesday's
night at eight TBS champ TNT Friday at
10 I'll help you out there it is
appreciate you pulling up no problem
thank you for having me boom